und Herren ich darf Sie recht herzlich
hier im designsenten Linz willkommen
heißen zur Pressekonferenz anlässlich
der IKD Sicherheitskonferenz
2023 an meiner Seite darf ich begrüßen
die Verteidigungsministerin Claudia
Tanner den Leiter des abwehramtes Herrn
Generalmajor Reinhard ruckenstuhl und
den Präsidenten der FH Oberösterreich
Gerald
Reisinger sehr geehrte Frau Minister ich
würde sie um ihre eröffnungsw suchen
vielen Dank sehr geehrter Herr
Generalmajor sehr geehrter Herr
Präsident sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
der Medien wir sind etwas außer Atem
weil man mit einem
Nobelpreisträger wie
Universitätsprofessor Zeilinger nicht so
schnell von einem Ort zum anderen kommt
weil das Interesse nach Fotos nach
kurzen Gesprächen gerade hier heute bei
dieser IKD Konferenz natürlich etwas ist
das man sie einfach abhol hen will
allein das ist schon eine große Leistung
dass das gelungen ist Herr Generalmajor
Herrn Universitätsprofessor heute
hierher zu bekommen zu einem Thema das
wir mittlerweile seit vielen Jahren im
Fokus haben nämlich der Entwicklung des
cyberbereiches auch bei uns oder gerade
bei uns beim österreichischen Bundesheer
denn sehr geehrte Damen und Herren es
ist ein Faktum dass Cyberattacken neben
Pandemien Terrorangriffen regionalen
Konflikten zu sehr wahrscheinlichen
Einsatzszenarien unserer Zeit gehören
und wenn Sie nur daran denken dass wir
als österreichisches Bundesheer ja für
den Schutz auch der kritischen
Infrastruktur zuständig sind wenn Sie
daran denken wie abhängig lebenswichtige
Einrichtungen sind wie z.B die
Stromnetze Wasserversorgung
Gesundheitseinrichtungen
Finanzsysteme dann weiß man dass wir
diesen Szenarien im seiberraum unser
besonderes Augenmerk auch eben
geben müssen unsere Experten im Ressort
erstellen jährlich ein risikobild wo man
eben sieht wie wahrscheinlich welche
Szenarien sind und wenn man gerade an
den großen Cyberangriff auf das
Außenministerium unter anderem denkt vor
ein paar Jahren wenn wir den Angriff
Putins auf die Ukraine vor uns haben und
welche Begleiterscheinungen dieser auch
mit sich bringt im cyberbereich dann
wissen wir als österreichisches Bund her
dass wir uns darauf vorbereiten müssen
auf diese Herausforderungen der
Austausch sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
mit Experten im Bereich Cyber Security
der ist von größter Bedeutung der ist
von größter Bedeutung für die nationale
Sicherheit unseres Landes mit der IKD
Sicherheitskonferenz versammeln wir in
Wahrheit die europäische Elite auf
diesem Gebiet wir bieten Raum um
Synergien zu schaffen jedes Jahr findet
sie in einem anderen Bundes Stadt und
heute sind wir eben in Oberösterreich wo
wir ja bereits eine enge Beziehung haben
über den Fachhochschulbereich auch aber
dazu wird der Herr Präsident dann
näheres auch noch erzählen seit 10
Jahren gibt's diese IKD Sicherheits
Konferenz seit mehr als 10 Jahren und
sie hat sich entwickelt zur größten
deutsch im deutschsprachigen Raum zur
größten ihrer Art im deutschsprachigen
Raum das ist für uns als
österreichisches Bundesheer deshalb auch
wichtig weil wir laufen auf der Suche
nach Talenten sind in diesem
Fach wir haben das große Glück mit der
Wehrpflicht grundwerdiener zu haben
damit auch
cybergrundwerdiener zu haben die bei uns
im bundesher einen unglaublich wichtigen
Beitrag leisten und wir bemühen uns dass
wir so viele wie möglich von ihnen auch
an unserer Seite halten wir haben auch
einen neuen fachhochschulbachelor
Studiengang für militärische
informations und
kommunikationstechnologische Führung ins
Leben gerufen um eben zukünftige IKT
Offiziere äh
hervorzubringen äh wenn sie sich schon
etwas umgeschaut haben sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die diesjährige IKD
Sicherheitskonferenz bietet wieder
einige besondere Dinge das beginnt beim
aktuellen österreichischen cyberraum
über kriminelle Machenschaften im
Cyberspace geht hin bis zum Weltraum da
werden jeweils die neuesten Erkenntnisse
auch präsentiert ja und wie schon kurz
angesprochen Schwerpunkt ist ohne
Zweifel auch das was sich auch im
cyberraum durch den ukrainekrieg
verändert hat und da wird z.B der
russische cyberkonflikt die Auswirkungen
auf Politik und Wirtschaft dargestellt
in verschiedenen Breakout Sessions
können spezielle Themen vertieft werden
und ich glaub ans wird uns wirklich
atemlos machen denke ich her general
herr Präsident es wird ein Live hacking
auch geben das zeigt
wie einfach es eigentlich ist dass man
in unterschiedliche Systeme sich auch
einschleust sie haben einige vielleicht
schon gesehen hier beim herumgehen die
diese leiberloch tragen die austure
Cyber Security Challenge da findet jetzt
auch der Finalwettkampf statt seit 10
Jahren wirklich sehr beliebt und auch
dem gewidmet dass wir talentierte junge
Menschen eben frühzeitig entdecken
können ihre Fähigkeiten und Kenntnisse
dann entsprechend auch fördern können im
Finale treten jetzt 40 Wettkämpferinnen
an wir unterstützen das als Bundesheer
schon sehr lange und ich möchte an
dieser Stelle auch dem verantwortlichen
Verein der cyb Security Austria danken
für diesen reibungslosen und
erfolgreichen Ablauf
vielen vielen Dank ja danke auch beim
Team meines Hauses Federführung
natürlich beim abwamt Herr Generalmajor
ruckenstuhl aber auch Herrn oberstunger
der sehr vielen von ihnen ja bekannt ist
für die so wichtige langjährige Arbeit
im Dienst der cybersicherheit im
speziellen auch für die Ausrichtung
unserer sich Sicherheits Konferenzen ja
und ein ganz großes Dankeschön an die
Fachhochschule Oberösterreich für diese
langjährige langjährige Kooperation in
diesem Bereich unverzichtbar sich zu
vernetzen mit der Wissenschaft mit der
Forschung das ist das einzige Rezept das
uns hilft in den Bedrohungen die vor uns
liegen wir müssen zusammen arbeiten
international fachübergreifend und wir
müssen uns laufend weiterbilden das ist
das Ziel von der
Sicherheitskonferenz und ich ist daher
auch die Fortbildung von unseren
Sicherheitsexperten aus allen Bereichen
weil es am Ende des Tages sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren um unser aller
Sicherheit um die nationale Sicherheit
von uns allen geht ich danke Ihnen als
nächstes ersuche ich den Leiter des
abwehramtes Herrn Generalmajor Reinhard
ruckenstuhl um seine Worte sehr geehrte
Damen und
Herren die IKD sich
Sicherheitskonferenz ist klarerweise
auch ein Ausdruck dass das BMLV also das
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
ein proaktiver und ein integraler
Bestandteil der
cyberersicherheitslandschaft in
Österreich ist allein der Titel aber
sagt schon dass wir uns sowohl mit den
Chancen aber auch mit den Risken
beschäftigen
müssen es gibt die unterschiedlichsten
Formeln um Risken darstellen zu können
man kann es aufbrechen in
Wahrscheinlichkeit Verwundbarkeit mal
auswikung und dagegen werden immer
Maßnahmen zu setzen wie bereitet man
sich vor wie bildet man ein Lagebild ab
wie schützt man die eigenen Systeme bzw
wie verhält man sich im
Schadensfall und darauf versuchen wir
Anregung bzw teilweise auch Antworten im
Rahmen dieser Konferenz zu geben wir
brauchen uns nur vor Augen zualten was
sind die
Herausforderungen im Bereich Cyber in
den nächsten Jahren und ich bringe nur
exemplarisch ein paar Schlagworte es
wurde schon im Vortrag vom Professor
Zellinger auch klar dargelegt
quantencomuting und Kryptographie das
bietet Chancen wird uns aber vor allem
in der Kryptographie auch vor besondere
Herausforderungen in den nächsten Jahren
stellen Internet of things jeder von
ihnen hat irgendein device eingesteckt
das mit dem Internet kommuniziert all
das sind eintrittsmöglichkeiten in
unmittelbaren privaten Bereich auch
künstliche Intelligenz maschinelles
Lernen Social engenierung Engineering
also soziale Manipulation und
fisching und mehrfach bereits
angesprochen die Frau Bundesminister hat
es auch angesprochen der Mangel an
Fachkräften allein in Österreich sind
wir bei über
30.000 it relevanten Stellen die nach
entsprechend qualifizierten Potenzial
und Personal rufen und auch wir als
österreichisches Bundesheer sind nicht
gefeit davor uns diesem Wettbewerb am
Personalmarkt zu stellen und versuchen
daher auch entsprechende Angebote
bzw um im selberbereich auch
interessante Jobs mit Möglichkeiten die
sich vielleicht woanders
darstellen
anzubieten wozu dient oder was ist das
Spirit der IKD Sicherheit erenz des
österreichischen Bundesheeres erstens
soll es einmal dazu dienen zur
Bewusstseinsbildung seIber ist ein
integraler Bestandteil unseres täglichen
Lebens jeder erwartet sich dass es
funktioniert und wenn es nicht
funktioniert ist man vielleicht ein
bisschen erstaunt aber hat keine Ahnung
warum
Wissensaustausch es sind Experten
international und national hier an einem
Standort
zusammengeführt worden um hier Ideen
auszutauschen Wissenstransfer zu
ermöglichen
Netzwerkaufbau ganz wichtiger
Bestandteil der seberersicherheit nur
gemeinsam kann man Erfolge erzielen ein
single source Vorgang ist nicht immer
der richtige weil es in sich in
verschiedenste Domänen ausbreitet wo wir
Bedrohungen begegnen müssen aber
klarerweise wollen wir auch neue
Technologien und Lösungen
vorstellen eines muss uns aber auch ganz
klar sein unser Credo ist auch immer
dass wir die User im Endeffekt
sensibilisieren wollen wie ist mit dem
Phänomen Cyber bzw wie umzugehen bzw wie
kann ich mich auch selber schützen ween
eines muss klar sein der häufigste
Angriffsvektor läuft noch immer über
E-Mail Attachments die
ohne große Überlegungen geöffnet werden
und das kann massiven Schaden wie wir es
mehrfach in den letzten Jahren erlebt
haben sowohl im unternehmerischen
Bereich aber auch im
Sicherheitsbereich bewirken daher unsere
Message nehmen Sie so viel als möglich
mit Infos von dieser von dieser
Konferenz und se sie ein bisschen
vorsichtiger welches Email und welches
attachment Sie das nächste Mal öffnen
danke abschließend suche ich den
Präsidenten der FH oberösterreichn
Gerald Reisinger um seine Worte ja meine
Damen und Herren seitens der FH
Oberösterreich auch herzlich willkommen
ich bedanke mich für Interesse an
unserer Arbeit ich bedanke mich gleich
zu Beginn bei der Frau Minister bei
Herrn Generalmajor für diese lange
jährige Partnerschaft und Zusammenarbeit
die ich mit Fug und Recht glaube iches
Erfolgsmodell bezeichnen kann und sie
verzeihen Frau Minister ganz besonders
möchte ich den Herrn Unger vor den
Vorhang holen er ist so unsere unser
Bottleneck zum Ministerium in all den
ganzen täglichen kleinen und größeren
sorgen und ein Garant für die Stabilität
und für die ausgezeichnete
Zusammenarbeit was können wir dazu be
beitragen zu den Themen die meine
Vorredner schon angesprochen haben wir
können ein Stück Ausbildung liefern wir
können ein Stück Fachkräfte und
Nachwuchs liefern und der Oberst so
treffend auf der Bühne draußen gesagt
der ist ganz stolz dass ein paar Leute
die bei uns durchgegangen sind
mittlerweile bei ihm arbeiten und das
ist immer so das positivste Feedback
dass man als ausbildungsstätdte auch
bekommen kann wenn man persönen
Persönlichkeiten 3 f Jahre ausbildet
dann hinaus zum Bedarfsträger in die
Wirtschaft in die Gesellschaft in den
öffentlichen Bereich schickt und dann
kriegt man positives Feedback wo dann
der nutznisser sagt super Leid toll
desand Rück hat meine Abteilung und
danke auch für dieses Kompliment wo
arbeiten wir noch mit wir arbeiten bei
der IKT Sicherheitskonferenz Partner mit
schon seit Jahren weil wir einfach von
der Bedeutung des Themas überzeigt sind
und denke wir können auch da den einen
oder anderen kleinen be
liefern und was wir vor allem auch ganz
ganz wichtig ist neben der Ausbildung
wir arbeiten auch in der Forschung sehr
intensiv zusammen wir haben einige
substanzielle gemeinsame
Projekte durchgezogen wir haben begonnen
mit kleineren bilateralen Projekten das
ist liegt in der Natur der Sache man
gewinnt Vertrauen zueinander und wir
haben es in den letzten Jahren zwei ganz
große FFG Kiras Projekte gemeinsam
umgesetzt wovon eines noch weiterluft
und hoffentlich auch in Zukunft
weiterlaufen wird in diesem Sinne danke
an alle Partner für die vertrauensvolle
Zusammenarbeit für die Unterstützung und
stehe natürlich selbstverständlich
derzeit für Fragen zur Verfügung
herzlichen Dank sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Werte Medienvertreter gibt es
noch
Fragen danke le von der App ich hätte
zwei Fragen zum einen an die Frau
Ministerin wie gut ist denn das
bundesjahr aufgestellt was die
seersicherheit angeht also im eigenen
Bereich und zum anderen an den Herrn
ruckenstuhl was sind denn die
großen
Bedrohungen hinsichtlich Infrastruktur
auf welches Szenarien auf welcheenaren
stellen sie sich da ein und woher kommt
die Gefahr sind das andere Staaten sind
das Terrororganisationen normale
Kriminelle mit finanziellen Absichten
ja ja wir sind auf einem sehr guten Weg
dass wir auch im Bereich der Cyber
Defense auf der Höhe der Zeit sind aber
wenn ich sage wir sind auf einem Weg
dann meine ich damit dass wir die
entsprechenden budgetären Mittel zum
einen haben und damit entsprechend
unseres aufbauplanes investieren werden
in all das was notwendig ist das ist ein
namhafter Millionenbetrag dazu auch
vorgesehen die Herausforderung und drum
ist eine Vernetzung auch mit
mit den
ausbildungsstädten so wichtig die
Herausforderung wird sein und da haben
wir sehr viel
Notwendigkeiten aufzuwachsen das ist das
entsprechende Personal warum es sind uns
gewisse Schranken durch die
Bezahlsysteme durch die Besoldung im
öffentlichen Dienst gesetzt das war auch
das was angesprochen worden ist vom Herr
Generalmajor ruckenstuhl wir müssen was
die personellen Gegebenheiten anbelangt
aufwachsen daher auch eine Kooperation
so wie sie mit der FH bt wird die dann
dazu führt dass die ausgebildeten auch
tatsächlich bei uns eben wie genannt
beim oberstunger in der entsprechend
zuständigen Abteilung danch tätig sind
und dass uns die Wirtschaft nicht
abzieht das ist unabdingbar notwendig
als ich formuli so wir sind auf dem
richtigen Weg tatsächlich auch in diesem
Bereich zu einer modernen Armee im
Bereich der Cyber deffens zu
werden wenn ich kurz auf die zweite
Frage eingehen darf kritische
Infrastruktur wie eingangs erwähnt
Digitalisierung schreitet voran auch
kritische Infrastruktur ist hier ein
wesentlicher Bestandteil dass die
Funktionalität gegeben ist wir sind ja
auch gemeinsam mit dem Bundesministerium
für Inneres in der sogenannten iktok dem
inneren Kreis der operativen
Koordination um hier unser no-how
gemeinsam vortragen zu können jeder in
seiner speziellen Fähigkeit und und
Expertise was sind die größeren Herr
Herausforderungen staatliche Akteure
oder kriminell rein quantitativ gesehen
ist nach wie vor der Kriminelle Zugang
noch immer bei weiten der überwiegende
es ist aber heute auch schon mehrfach
angesprochen worden der Ukraine Russland
Konflikt und das legt schon und das
bringt schon klar zu Tage dass auch
staatlich gesteuerte bzw Organisationen
mit staatlichen Hintergrund stärk
hier Gefährdungen projizieren sowohl in
den wirtschaftlichen aber auch in den
Kernbereich der Funktionalität von
Staaten Absichten dahinter können
unterschiedlich sein das eine wie wir es
erlebt haben z.B bei Beginn Ukraine
Russland Konflikt die Zerstörung von
Systemen so dass Systeme nicht mehr
funktionieren eine andere Absicht kann
sein das Absaugen von Informationen um
hierenor Vorteil zu gewinnen
bzw weitere
angriffsvktoren darstellen zu können
oder die dritte Absicht die klassisch
kriminelle Erpressung wir finden es
immer wieder öfter in den in den Medien
große Firmen werden hier attackiert und
mit
Lösegeldzahlungen konfrontiert der
Vizepräsident der Wirtschaftskammer hat
heute gebracht man diskutiert bereits
wie in weit sind Lösegeldzahlungen auch
steuerlich absetzbar also das sind die
Bedrohungen denen wir uns vor allem
jetzt im Bereich der kritischen
Infrastruktur ausgesetzt sehen unser
Bestreben ist natürlich hier gemeinsam
mit den anderen mit unseren Partnern im
im staatlichen Umfeld vor allem die
Resilienz und die
Widerstandsfähigkeit dieser Systeme zu
stärken und das ist eine eindeutige
Notwendigkeit um die Funktionalität
sicherzustellen gibt es noch weitere
Fragen
nachdem es keine Fragen mehr gibt
bedanke ich mich und erkläre die
Pressekonferenz für